[Music]
in born this way news submitted by AJ
from New Jersey
whatever AJ Joisey scientists have
uncovered genes linked to being
transgender we're scientists like you
been transgender homie is that the
discovery like yes Abby it's been
predetermined while you were already in
your bonuses people against it are like
no get rid of this information yeah so
scientists are saying that they have
uncovered 20 genes linked to being
transgender that's exciting that makes
sense words the claims that you people
weren't born this way you don't choose
to be the same with um being homosexual
yep if they make sense that its genetic
yeah make sense I've heard from
somewhere that it was if it's from the
mom's side of the family and so is
balding huh
it's carried on through the modeling is
on the side I don't know about the whole
sexual gene marry that I don't know but
if my son's super duper flamin I won't
be like that's partly you an twins run
in the family too
yes yeah there's like genetic that's
cool and it could be gay twins yeah we
have a friend that has twin brothers oh
yeah oh wait I know yours like the same
DNA Saturday oh dude he's not gay but
his brother's gay but they're twins but
one straight oh this is this pretty dope
for the transgender community oh yeah
shove it in everyone's faces like you
see all the haters yeah are their haters
doors it just well yeah yeah they're
haters Fox time there are a lot of
people that say it's psychological and
like a shock they're like you started
way back in the day like you got to get
it out of you like we gotta bring it out
shock therapy [ __ ] medication all
that it's a mental disorder I just don't
know where these people are so I'm just
kind of confused like is it really the
majority is it half of the population is
it a schmuck who are these people cuz
like I'm just saying it's the non
thinking people like I won't even be
surprised my dad thought that well never
be like
that's old-fashioned he probably thinks
gay being gay as a choice or your MIT
major that way or he probably thinks
like if you're transgender and you feel
like you're stuck in the wrong body you
need to sort your [ __ ] out there's more
important things to do like get a job
before you want to cut your dick off
like my dad's probably part of the old
school one time in their defense because
I've argued with these people before I
got you know no my dad's not like that
but like like some some people that I
think are very intelligent they just
don't quite understand or they're trying
to trying to understand and like that
the way that they can accept things is
after they can understand understanding
of it and I think before there was
scientific evidence in their minds it
was still up for a debate and they just
wanted to find a way to help people
because there are people that they're
not trying to be ignorant they just want
to do the best thing to help and and if
there's no scientific evidence then they
can say well maybe it's a mental
disorder and so I don't think everyone's
just like a hater like they chose that
life like I think some people are
genuinely like well since there's no
proof yet that there just make their own
assumption maybe it's this maybe we
could try this and and those people I
think are like I think you should judge
people by intent rather than like what
they're actually saying yeah cuz now
that there's scientific evidence now
they they'd probably be ones to accept
that and be like oh well then I was
wrong it's really dope yeah that's
really [ __ ] dope agent old Asian
people don't listen to science they
don't vote they just think it's a
science is just a suggestion
just like religion like offended by it
yeah they're just like proof
I could write anything in a newspaper
and that could be proof too because my
dad would be the one-eyed but oh that's
awesome that there's all this scientific
evidence but have you really tried like
[ __ ] a guy hooker or a girl hooker to
really figure out like what you want to
be like that would be his solution and
then you'd be like there's facts dad and
you're like I don't know that facts
don't tell you everything
that's a good feel like that would be a
Joe shirt yeah I'll tell you everything
[Laughter]
JK Bert shirt for reals though facts
don't tell you everything I don't
believe in facts alternative facts yeah
I feel like it's kind of like this weird
witch hunt almost for like anti-gay anti
transgender people because like maybe
because I live in LA and I'm surrounded
by people who just it's not something
that even is up for debate it exists and
also like just because I'm a history
buff and I know how this is this has
been going on for ancient times
homosexuality trend all that stuff and
it's like well aside from you know
Christianity and these different
religions that probably shunned that
stuff it's been a part of culture like
yeah for so many years so I'm just like
why is this new did you watch that movie
the Danish girl yes yeah and that was
like way way back then it was a good-ass
yeah was that the first time someone
tried to do a surgical procedure yeah
it's about this guy who's will girl
who's transgender and he's he doesn't
realize it yet he's born a dude though
yeah he was born a dude and then was
yeah married to this beautiful woman and
then for fun like she's like hey dress
wear my dress or whatever she was
painting something yeah and then he
really likes it and then he starts kind
of wearing her clothes a lot more and
then he like realizes that he's he
thinks he's a woman and it's really hard
it's really hard for both parties just
like guys I imagine it is now like
because he's like I have this is me this
is who I really am and she's like no but
I want my husband back and he's like but
this is this is who I am and so
eventually she supports him and he wants
to get a full sex change and back then
like they didn't have that sort of
technology or surgical procedure but
they he was kind of like a guinea pig
or she
and and then so she went through with it
I don't want to spoil the movie but like
the science wasn't as good back then so
it was a sweet story though they chopped
off they chopped up the weenies I don't
know they destroyed it you have to watch
it it's a great movie good and it's and
it brings like the humanity to it like
the of what what you go through when
you're born into a body that you don't
identify with I lived that every day
because and I'm supposed to be a
six-foot maniac like I did but that's
only one third of the race like I can't
conquer the world like this no but I'm
Napoleon client I'm five six in that era
I would have been an actually like buff
guy yeah like like 300 years ago I would
have been the man was it Napoleon about
that height yeah we're like five six but
so were all the other European guys
there everyone was like five three years
yeah
have you seen those little soldier yeah
they're [ __ ] cute those Warriors are
five three inches as you guys go to the
army museum in Paris yep like their
uniforms literally like from shoulder to
shoulder was like this it looks like a
you know the soldiers were like your
size male soldiers the little doors back
vent like click Hobbit doors that's just
me on an everyday [ __ ] everything go
in your direction at least you're it
you're leading her head to the crime you
know like even the people like the
Netherlands all the people there I
thought they were always tall and big
yeah me too but they weren't huh no
there's like a graph it just their
nutrition got better nutrition and like
breeding breeding yeah tall at all yeah
but its rival of the fittest a recent
phenomenon within a couple hundred years
it's nothing like they haven't been like
that the whole time so just as the world
is getting more populated we're also
getting bigger we found out there's
steroids there steroids in the water
over there probably I need that water
more protein yeah
is anything that you guys feel like what
we're talking about here like you just
feel like you were just born with that
nothing around your environment affected
it I've always always loved water like
since I was a kid so when I see the
beach when I see the swimming pool I've
always loved being in water so maybe I
was supposed water signs though oh but
maybe like five more to be fishing - you
can't like both just putting about that
next to water I just feel really calm I
just really like it I always wanted to
be a dude but that was not because I
identified with being a dude I just the
dudes got all the cooler things in my
name like yeah they got the better toys
the better Legos they got like I wanted
to be a comedian and they were all like
guys the guys the ones that I like for
guys and I just I just liked that stuff
better like I liked baseball yep we just
have all the fun
but then oh about now we're interested
in dolls and spill never I thought they
were freaky I thought dolls were like
yeah I didn't like things that look like
people I loved Barbies because when I
played with that I used to get like a
raging boner I didn't know why that's so
true always take all the clothes off
sexual I know I would like force myself
to play with my little cousin I'll be
like this is supposed to be fun yeah
this is fun
I like stuffed animals you know what
girls had that I wish I had is the
[ __ ] Easy Bake Ovens and the cook
I had that I was like I would see the
commercial and I'm like oh I want that
too but that's what girls baby I would
when I was 20 oh that's dope
but then I never you could have got a
real oven my dream of owning one but
then like I opened an actor for you I'm
just like hey I'm giving it to my like
my little cousin or something Oh
[Music]
you